our series a more perfect union aims to
show that what unites us as Americans is
far greater than what divides us even
before the coronavirus researchers said
4 in 10 Americans could not afford a car
repair or another unexpected expense of
just $400 but thanks to a groundbreaking
approach at one garage some don't have
to worry about such costs our Jam
Crawford shows us the mechanic and
military veteran who doesn't charge
anything at all will cry in my arms and
tell me how appreciative they are that I
fix their wiper blades
see how uneven the tire wear is wiping
away worry is Adam Ellie's work at
hard-luck Auto I joked about being the
only mechanic shop in the world that's
got a beer fridge that's open all day
you got your pick a Bud Light or Bud
Light you know veteran easy offers a
break on Auto Parts pop that clip right
there free labor Ducasse mechanic giving
more than just his home state Oklahoma a
jump starts a young lady message me she
said hey my car's broken down in
Michigan could we sleep in your parking
lot while you fix our car should come
all the way from Michigan to have her
car towed from Michigan because it's
cheaper to have me fix it for free than
it is for her to fix it in a different
time zone that idea to work without a
page that came after they hit hard luck
of their own
we lost everything lost everything we
ended up foreclosing on both of our
homes to be in such a tough spot and to
have just so recently kind of pulled
ourselves out of the ashes and rebuilt
what we had lost makes me even more
sympathetic to the cause
eally started with some tools in his
truck before long his hard luck service
calls caught the eye of micro Rose
Facebook show returning the favour' paid
a two-year lease on Ealy's own shop but
he keeps people like Ciaran Moynihan on
the road I want to put a new tire up
front so she can feed the homeless what
does that mean to you everything hi guys
Adam just did a fantastic job at it
appreciate didn't or you know he's right
where he needs to be giving back giving
back leave the jack in place giving back
has helped ground the former Army
helicopter mechanic after multiple tours
in Afghanistan this is my way of dealing
with my own kind of PTSD and my demons
is to be able to put a smile on
somebody's face every single day was
there a time in your life where you
didn't feel a lot of Hope yourself
oh so many times we lost six dudes in
one day
I can't affect that any more but I can
make America a better place you know I
can't I can I can't save the world but I
can change it and Alize done it by
changing more than just shocks and
struts he mentors junior mechanics like
16 year-old Cody bus was suspended from
school for fighting I love it because
you know I get to help people
you know seeing the smile on their face
but maybe they needed car part to get to
an interview for any job and you know we
help them out with that this is way more
than fixing cars this is huge this is so
far beyond anything I could have ever
imagined and it's 2020 is anything like
2019 stand back because we're just
getting started for CBS this morning I'm
Jan Crawford of Oklahoma City
- Thank You Adam you have guys like Adam
Eli and then you have jerks that are
selling sanitizer for $90 for a little
bottle yeah who do you want to know he's
a giant